we're too late the invasion is started
scan the emergency channels we need to
find out what's happening on the ground
Rangers are under heavy fire at the Hall
of Heroes and there's a floor transfer
closing it fast
brace for more bog reinforcements
Rangers civilians evacuate the area
we must assist the collecting Rangers
activating weapons systems weapons
online you may now attack the transport
enemy down budget now might be a good
time to test those weapons systems not
on my watch
floor transport down another transport
down it appears there are only three
ships left
yes we're on a roll one ship left
we still gotta take out that warship the
warbots
armor is made of a rare Italian alloy if
we could propel a warm part of the ship
with sufficient velocity I believe it
would penetrate the hull awesome and how
do we do that your weapon package
includes a mag Buster I am rewriting the
software to isolate the warbots armor
there you should now be able to pick up
warbots using the mag Buster okay let's
try this out
active there should be some war parts
nearby you can now pick them up and pull
them toward the warship
or box successfully magnetized setting
course for blog warship
wait for it
please
well done ratchet one-in-a-million let's
do it again
we have enough power for a few more
warbots if you make another pass
got him now let's send it back to where
they came from
present but my perseverance will defeat
these warbots you mean mag booster we
have enough power for a few more warbots
if you make another pass
warbots attached
we did it
all right everyone let's give these
heroes some breathing room